nach sorgen muss man ernst nehmen egal
wo sie auftreten
der bundesrat will unter bevölkerung in
unserem land zeigen dass wir ihre sorgen
ernst nehmen zum beispiel in grenchen
kanton solothurn eine arbeiterstadt im
wandel
grenchen ein seismograph für die
schattenseiten der globalisierung
[Musik]
mehrere krisen tötet macht ihm gehabt
ist mini crash zurückgestoßen der job
verlieren und frau verließ nachdem sich
der ruf des stoß
der heizkörper 8% rallye goslar bewies
das stärkt meine kiosk brauchen würde
das ist einfach mein name ist elisabeth
klinik rechtlich sorge ist dass mini job
findet beteiligung der kantonsrat 2
[Musik]
sie entstehen dort mensch ist da haben
wir schlecht die stimmbeteiligung das
monaten muss nicht mehr ausreicht
stimmung
26 juni von brock uhren arbeiter sowie
seine frau beatrice sechs alle
schrebergarten besitzer das beton
turnier ihr alljährliches highlight
[Musik]
es war und wieso
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ok erwartet europa bereits für die
größte tendenz dass sie den tanz dürfe
erst monate zwölf bekannte erwartet
voran helmut setzte oder anders
formuliert nennt er im schlafe in einer
der täter hatte das schicksal der nacht
mit mit eurem partner partnerin schlafen
die müllers bei der fdp-mitglieder
renate müller setzt für die partei auch
im gemeinderat dass ich mir eine frau
rosi die schafe peter schuler und dort
es aber grosse teil
russland findet es super schauspieler
die nicht irgendwie involviert und mit
sie natürlich august liest bringen
unterschätzte resultat das ist noch gar
nicht so einfach
die können jetzt grünen für sie stimmen
auf der liste zur gemeinderatswahl
[Musik]
im energiegesetz das intranet auf der
ligna svp sind die häufigste position
ändern weder durch fußgänger dort das
kommando
das land dann losgeht mit august und
[Musik]
wirtschaftlich kennen die müllers nicht
klagen aber sie stören sich an ihrem
umfeld in grenchen beziehen doppelt so
viele menschen sozialhilfe wie im
schweizer durchschnitt
die sp als traditionell stärkste partei
schwächelt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
milica und ivica dacic
sie stammen aus bosnien 27 jahre fußball
interessieren
[Musik]
grenchen die export stadt den
bilateralen verträgen mit der eu hat man
hier mehrmals zugestimmt
auch die müller stimmten für die
personenfreizügigkeit 2014 dann die
kehrtwende
jetzt wollten grenchen und die müllers
kontingente für ausländer
nirgendwo in der schweiz war der
meinungsumschwung größer es ist von der
menge und die aussehen der täter nicht
kann ich das einfach aufgeführt was man
stoppt macht und dass man das neue dot
regel ist sich bewusst dass die
bilateralen könnten ja das ist mir
eigentlich gar gestand gesehen und wenn
man es einfach lösungen
das ist ganz klar
[Musik]
ganz klar autoindustrie aber auch die
von burg haben ihre meinung geändert vom
jahr zur zuwanderung zum jahr zur
begrenzung der partei ich bin antworte
die bilateralen vertrag was beinhaltet
das er ist aber es ist einfach die ideen
normal also genau dann mal was ich nicht
so er könne nun gesagt hat damit gerade
mit dem markt gibt
[Musik]
politologen sagen verlierer der
globalisierung wählen oft gar nicht mehr
und viele leute des unteren mittelstands
wählen rechtskonservativ das gibt mir
der heimischen bank wenn ihr nach muss
klar dass das ist verständlich
das ist einfach typisch bosnische
spezialität täter heißt auch wissen
spruch oder wegen eines jobangebot zu
ihren mann hätten sie anfang der 1990 er
jahre in die schweiz kommen können so
einfach ja das ist so
[Musik]
nachrichten spezial
und jetzt auch noch das sp vp und ist
nun die stärkste parteien statt
[Musik]
die boomjahre längst vorbei hunderte
jobs in der uhrenindustrie weg eine neue
branche aber hat sich nie etabliert ist
die generation große wandlung mitgemacht
vorausgefüllt beim maschinenbau
[Musik]
wie lange also 2015
das macht schon zwischen vier und 500
franken wo ihnen fehle jedem monat
die globalisierung habe die
gewerkschaften machtlos gemacht
in der branche
[Musik]
der abschluss sieht sich vom august ist
er in form vom engagement her ist die
analyse ganz anderen milieu nach guter
profillosigkeit haben mich an genau
sagen dafür aus dass die stadt
migrationspolitik sozial auf zu wenig
wie opposition als fraktionschef
das sagen in der eu einbezogen werden es
geht nie aus dem blick
und wenn ich etwas mache ich meine
branche und das nicht weiter verfolgt
in der vergangenheit schneller abspielen
du bist als vorstandsmitglied und
schreiben implizite reagiert also
passieren dass der schnitt in der lage
ist überzeugt im so fit machen
doch da ist doch der lassen oder mit
nein stimmen sowie die politik nicht
mehr so thema portier formulieren und
letztlich und vermitteln stand unseres
dass wir uns falsch wie eine
verräterische position aber was bringt
es der politik zu machen
für manager boni ab touren oder für
menschen letztlich als vp danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ohne zu kompliziert
diesem bereich aber leider keine
währenddessen machen müsste aber
gedanken würde
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
abstimmen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
richtig
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass wochen halten
der städtische mittagstisch für
schulkinder
die meisten stammen aus ausländischen
familien die das speziell rücksicht auf
alte schweinefleisch das doch nicht alle
eltern hätten jobs einige mütter seien
den ganzen tag zu hause
das geht einfach schauen dass das mit
zum teil überfordert sie aber zwischen
klassik dass sie dort nach was ihre
bessere dass man das
stützen dass irgendwer schon irgendwie
einzelfälle sein dass vermutungen
[Musik]
das beschäftigt finanzieren und die
angst vor dem abstieg oder von bosch und
verlust
hallo
aber gott mann aus aber jetzt gerade
über die bilateralen verträge mit der eu
wird das hat tausenden oder
stillschweigend einig
wer angst hat abzusteigen welt häufig
svp politologen vermuten dass man sich
von gruppen mit tieferem sozialen status
abgrenzen will
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stimmen gerade nicht so gut laufen sagte
20 jahren hat frankreich im sturm und
habe jetzt haben kranke stunden
und wenn wir nicht rasch zu halten
denn passieren dass es keinen ärger für
sie dass sie findet da gebietet uns
nicht zusammen aber sie sind ja da ein
paar fotos ich glaube nicht so angebot
probiert was krank man nach dass sie
sich später machen
das ist eine motivation
[Musik]
my name is alias major service das glück
politischen und ihr beteiligen
wenn sie noch schenken möchte könnte mit
irgendwie krank aber sie verläuft das
schenken gibt verliehen ich liege jetzt
auch aktuelle politik das tryptophan xi
auf politik und eben zeige das jeweilige
gebäude quartier in panik wieder klingen
machen
der 21 jährige parteilose student
fordert den stadtpräsidenten heraus
françois scheidegger ein fdp mann
für die war ich mir dachte schon dass
ich mein eindruck haben der tat ihm
nicht wohl fühlt wie ariana fordert 15
haben wir sogar mit strikter aber man
muss ja konzerns wird es ständig ans
schweizer politik kompromiss werde der
stoff lässt natürlich aber starb als sie
dann gar nicht kann das ganze von grund
auf platt sprechen und eigentlich machen
machte die entscheidung sondern macht
wie man miteinander umgeht wunderschönen
nachmittag zum familie gartenfest viel
spaß
[Musik]
und meine
unterrichtet das modell beträgt 80 er
sich ziemlich sauer dass ich krank ist
wie ich meine kraft wenn du jetzt stau
präsident es mit 202 music hall ohne mit
irgend wo sich aufstellen das ist das
wohl nicht nur einen sprung von null auf
hundert gehen soll
das ist ja nicht von null auf hundert
neue verwaltung meint klinger als muss
seitdem übt ganz philipp das ist ein
fehler abstellt die heidi erfahrung
genau wie und ich bin überzeugt die
verwaltung schwierig wenn man jetzt so
wenig innovativ es braucht dort andere
ich hoffe dass nicht alles auf
o
[Applaus]
mitte der woche entdeckt und operiert
aber jetzt ist es könnte
ich bin daher sehr positiven cash ich
komme es nicht gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der boutique setzte kurz im moment
die große information
jannik was und wie es läuft und wir sind
mit allem rechnen
[Musik]
zwar tat ist das stimmbeteiligung ist
sagte 20,4 prozent und erscheint täglich
mit sachsens gehaut prozent genannt
worden
23 prozent das thema gemacht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke
[Applaus]
34 gleich nach dem treffen wir stehen ja
klar
starnberg mittels machen weg von mir
sondern so richtig schön dass mein
geschleppt was heißt das denn die n tv
wird völlig österreich das ist doch kein
jagddruck haut und mit den emotionen
summe feldüberlegen aber völlig leeren
die möglichkeit mit uns diskutieren was
kranke bewegt man traut sich ja das ist
wie möglich zeit hat politikkonzept
verbaute glücklich wenn man jetzt
geführt mehr wird abgeschossen in der
hand geben los nein zu sagen
doch jeder möglichen sprach stunde auf
niedrigen oder auch das hat unser
festgestellt dass größten haben einfach
drum herum version ist eigentlich
einfach also das kann man schon machen
also die spannung aufrecht
dennoch gereinigt oder chelsea
wir haben
[Musik]
naja so schlüssel weg als wichtigste
ziele in ordnung hat und dort zu solcher
beiträge aus den analogen deutlicher
bietet der bgg sie glauben sie was sind
die größten sorgen schweizer sogenannte
koma schließlich autos also wieder
passiert ist für uns weiter so wie das
mit russland aber einige schweizer
ich habe jetzt ein paar leica zum
beispiel schreibt mir das bürgerforum
machen und sinnvollere klein zusammen
ich aber nicht politiker oder der
gemeinde dort antragsteller sondern der
betrug an der heute die angst vor zu
bringen wenn sie ansteigen als passiert
ich sag das jetzt einfach wenn ihm einig
sagte pyka kartons und kaka dass sie
nachher einfach nur immer so darf doch
okay wenn ich bis jetzt mache sei genau
das ist genau dass ich das problem
diskutieren
man kann diskutieren darüber diskutieren
wie so oft weitaus höheren groß mit so
vielen tiere schlafen und klingt ja ja
ja da war ich ausland nach kathrin o
jetzt hat er wenig kollege kommt er wie
trink ich lieber wieder andere sagte
aber jeder mitbringen bringt eine
flasche jetzt wäre wäre natürlich hat
die weiße york ist einfach der wurm kann
das ist das gesetz genau das ist was die
quartiere sind das ist jetzt selbst über
das neue ist versuchen die show und
ermordeten sie zu punkten ist und jetzt
aber geschäft verschaffen ist einfach es
besteht ja das marketing ist richtung
auf die andere ist fuchs probieren und
die schweizer seite mit kindern server
game also ein zum beispiel der spruch
mit töre kommt ist ganze familie
ablehnte nachdem es mit dem gewinner auf
die gedämpfte da machen einschlafen zu
viel los
der balkan schlechte kriminalwache
gestohlen
ausgehöhlte 44 und und wisse der spitze
dass das dass es auch dass russland
werden wird diskriminiert konnte ich
auch nicht dass keine chance ihr bestes
video portalen schäfer gab damit damit
mit der schweiz über das thema bei den
damen dass wir alle von gran canaria
springt um darüber diskutiert dass man
so anders dass man mich behandelt als
schweizer nicht als problemlöser vor
diskriminierung ist ob das klappt das
ist absoluter rekord diskutierte das ist
also die wand
ich war nicht ganz so diskutiert ja
sowieso wenn ich nicht kenne was müsste
man da machen das ist nicht so sie
scheint zu wissen weil es bequem oder
gar nicht wann prototyp erklären dass
sie mir sogar diskutieren
ich möchte möglichkeit schaffen machen
findet man standort noch nie und daran
ändert sich nichts
elias meyer verfolgt die idee des
bürgerforums nicht weiter stören
skifahren es mehr und mehr gefährlich
[Musik]
die gerichtskommission hat gemäss
protokoll vom 27 stellte insgesamt zeigt
sich behandelt das haben jetzt auch um
staatsangehörige aus kosovo serbien
italien sowie lanka romani deutschland
und mazedonien motto punkt 33 65 das ist
teil familie aus kosovo gesagt als der
ehefrau von fürst steht nicht im gesetz
geschlossen ist weil sie der
schriftliche teil vom sprach stands nach
wie es nicht kann erfuhren dass kranke
sehr strenge gerichtsverfahren musik die
ganze familie
es ist besser wenn dieser schulservice
schiff mit rede nur nur schafe und sie
haben gesagt ich möchte auch wenn ich
möchte deutschland heißt sie davor zu
lasten des mieters jetzt direkt wie
jetzt die nikotin ist ein outing
schneemaschinen bizerba bisschen irre
klamm ihrer diese chefs vorschlage
muskulatur in whistler interessiert euch
denn die politik möchtet ihr wirklich
wählen
mit soviel interessieren - wie nie mehr
interessiere sport und musik und gute
frau und diese straße lief was werden
wie sie der vorteil werden sie in
schweizer haushalten
seit 27 jahren 28 gut vorstellen schweiz
unfallfrei und alt den niedrigeren
stufen wo man sich doppelt aus
erschüttert wir brauchen einfach mehr
jung aber ich versichere ich mir
vorstelle wieder freiraum geben sie auch
zu strom soll
haben sie fragen zum teil ja dass sich
zwei markt
[Musik]
der 18 jährige lehrling stefan ist seit
längerem im einbürgerungs prozess die
kommission hat sein gesuch noch nicht
behandelt und erklärt us broker ob du
mehr schweizer konzerns mit russland ok
wie soll ich das gefühl nicht so wichtig
hab zu reden miteinander und wachstum
vielleicht wenn sich mit russland sagte
sie genau wieso kurzschluss am anfang so
person ins auge bevor wenn ich mich
darauf aus einer familie durch versetzte
der wird die die meine jungs familie und
und stasi behörde gelegt zusammen
der haftrichter habe neben reicher sind
beim aufstieg er ist einfach der familie
ist nach außen verstanden ist für seine
rechtlichen kultur im internet service
oft ob das gesetz aber verlangt dass
jeder einbürgerungswillige person
separat beurteilt wird
die gelegenheit wie sie die bürger meint
im bild gelobt so sehr viel frust groß
wäre eine vom kanton über diese röck
einfach bestimmt dass sie und der
kantone liebe geht obwohl mehr ist und
mit mainz versammlung dann jetzt
allerdings nicht mehr probieren jetzt
fahren wenn man einfach machtlos ist
gerade die entwicklung aktionären
[Musik]
dort findet er ja klassen daher mit
vielen tricks prozent ausländer wenn die
auch niemand übel dass er steinbrück hat
hier schon das stimmt schon
überhaupt zu artikeln
[Musik]
bisher zweiter unserem lud sprache
wie gut sie in die dynamische themes
bereit je nach rust - um die wird sie
sind die schweizermacher von grenchen
die einwohner mit bürgerrecht mirbach
inzwischen fährt bis 15 das entspricht
aber nur drei prozent aller grenchner
bürger dass sie funktioniert das wenn
diese haare vor feindlicher heimatstube
hätte für diese kultur
das sind ganze geld
[Musik]
wer gemäß seiner ganz herzlich zu
unserer heutigen ordentlichen wirklich
mainz versammeln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
historisch gewachsene der theater 69
unter die ausliefen
ich möchte die an der tasso
europameister und arrogant
das sieht es wirklich aus gegangen vor
der frau besteht allerdings noch
vorbehalt sie muss nur finanzielles
fertig ist wird das zu 60 stimmen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er hat eine art krieg zustimmen soll das
bitte bezüge mit anderen
damit war thema die bergige ab 2
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben sieben gefallen
der traunsee consult vielleicht wird ja
gut dass antworten und die der familie
war also erschafft also in die pkv die
wisag und pensionskosten bietet als
erstes kommt probieren jetzt der
gemeinheit
die warum das 96 co mit finanzieller
solidarität in den größer
produkteigenschaft beschloss ein gericht
habe zwar jetzt
[Musik]
aber kranke speziell ja nicht unbedingt
sondern auch senioren
[Musik]